foreign
[Music]
hello and welcome to A View From 22
where The Spectator takes another look
and perhaps a deeper look at something
in the news I'm Kate Andrews the
spectator's economics editor and I'm
joined by Freddie gray our Deputy editor
hi Freddy great to be with you Kate uh
now this is a fascinating development
over the weekend we have unlocked the
Twitter files Elon Musk has been
promising that he was eventually going
to reveal what happened back in 2020
when Twitter took down a major political
story about Hunter Biden's laptop
leading up to the election between
Donald Trump and Joe Biden before we
dive into what's been revealed can you
take our audience back to 2020 leading
up to the election when the New York
Post drops the hunter Biden laptop story
what is it what are the revelations in
the story and why did Twitter ban it
well do you think it's worth going back
because a lot of it's lost in the fog of
the pandemic and it feels like a lot
further back in time than it actually
was
um so the story essentially is that uh
uh supposedly some people question this
story uh a computer repair shop owner
called John Paul Mack Isaac which I
always like that that's his name his
last name is Mac his Mac Isaac yeah uh
he's a real person and maybe he has a
computer business he has a computer up
in Delaware and Hunter Biden left this
laptop and he found it and discovered
all these sort of shocking things on it
including lots of pornography involving
Hunter Biden but also lots of emails
detailing Hunter Biden's peculiar and I
would say nefarious business dealings
with China and Ukraine now what seems to
have happened after that is that the FBI
uh went around tell well um John Paul
mcnize actually took it to the FBI and
so nothing ever happened it seems like
they just sat on it but at some point
the FBI
uh started warning big tech companies
that there was a big misinformation leak
big fake news leak similar to what might
have happened in 2016 uh which would be
a foreign entity interfering in the
election by dropping damaging news about
one of the presidential candidates
um whether they actually specified this
was about Hunter Biden we're not
entirely sure the New York Post has a
very interesting front page story about
it suggesting that they did
um so they sent out this morning to
companies and then so when the New York
Post broke this uh huge story really a
very very interesting story at a very
important moment in the election cycle
about not just as people are sneering on
the weekend it's not just about photos
of Hunter Biden's penis no one really
cares about that be Beyond an Allure a
lot of people don't want to see that a
lot of people do even we're more weirdly
but it's a mixed bag out there but
that's that's not the sort of political
theme point of the story is that there
is this the New York's post uh original
big scoop was that there is this email
about a deal that Hunter Biden was
involved in involving the Chinese
where there is this email that writes
off 10 for the big guy we don't know
that the big guy is Joe Biden but it
could be and that's a very very
intriguing development at a crucial
stage in the election but because of
These Warnings it seems from the FBI uh
Twitter about hacking Twitter labeled it
as hacked material and shut the story
down and they shut the stories down so
much that they treated it like
they use the same means of sort of
shutting it down as they do for child
pornography so you can't share it via
direct message you couldn't the link was
sort of completely nuked really and so
much so that even the White House
spokesman at the time Kaylee mcenany
mcaneny uh her account was shut down
because she tweeted about the story so
it was again in the days leading up
now of course we have a new owner of
Twitter and he's been promising for
weeks Elon Musk in his usual sort of
trouble causing way to to do this big
reveal and this was the first this at
the weekend we have the first reveal
there's meant to be more coming about
what actually happened at Twitter and
right before we get into the start of
the Twitter files if we stay in 2020 for
just a minute longer uh and you know no
one really wants to live in 2020 for too
long tough year pandemic all of it but
it was great we're gonna be there for
just one more minute Fred
um at the time the journalists at the
New York Post were flipping out saying
you know this is a suppression of free
speech this is crucial information this
is public information leading up to a a
presidential election uh and and Twitter
did not budge
Twitter did not budge and what is clear
from these I'm going to get into the
files a little bit here I'm afraid what
is clear from the uh exchanges that Matt
toibi this uh American journalist who
must seems to be using to release this
on Twitter what's clear is that the
senior Executives at Twitter
knew that what they were doing was not
really sustained it wasn't really
ethical or moral or right and yet they
just sort of went ahead with it anyway
because they'd agreed to this hacked
material
stuff they were obviously very worried I
think Mark Zuckerberg sent it with
Facebook that all meta that uh they were
very worried about
um a repeat of 2016 where the wrong side
might win and they would be blamed what
they do as the wrong side what they've
used the wrong side exactly
um but as Elon Musk has said it was as
if Twitter was acting as an executive
arm of the Democratic National Committee
so let's dive right into the full
material um interestingly Elon Musk has
decided to start revealing the Twitter
files through a journalist Matt taibi
through a Twitter thread which is very
meta and not the other social media
platform in that case yeah
um and you know we're starting to get
some serious glimpses I mean it's a
release of emails uh you know so exactly
what these people were thinking and
writing down at the time about what was
going through their head and there's
some fascinating Revelations
um the first I want to get into well
there's actually let's talk about the
broad theme there's a nervousness
amongst those Executives as you point
out you can tell that there's sitting
there thinking what if we're blamed for
doing the wrong thing yes and I guess
that also shows the extent more broadly
speaking to which you know the
insistence that social media platforms
get these things just right and ban the
right things and allow the right things
I mean that really comes to a head in
the hunter Biden story well it's I mean
it's really about uh ass covering if I
can use that word I think so this past
midday okay because they are they're not
so much worried about whether it's
morally wrong to politically censor a
story they're worried uh about how it's
going to look and how can they really
justify when they face hard questions
but possibly Congressional hard
questions further well there's a line in
there about how Jack the owner at the
time uh would be facing questions about
this in one of in one of the hearings
that he already has scheduled coming up
so essentially they had to get the call
right based on what he might be asked by
politicians yes I think that's an
interesting element to that story
actually is tybee's very clear Keen to
say that he's seen nothing suggesting
Jack Dorsey had anything to do with it
yeah but that might also be the fact
that musk and Jack Dorsey I think are
pretty pretty Pally pretty close as far
as I know uh so perhaps they want to
make sure that he's insulated from these
Revelations I think one of the biggest
Revelations out of the the start of what
presumably we're going to get in the
Twitter files
um is an email dated Saturday October
24th 2020. so at this point you know we
are days away from the election
um in which there's a series of links
from Twitter users and it reads more to
review from the Biden team
it seems as though there was a direct
link between the Biden team and is also
acknowledged to a lesser extent the
Trump team in which they were sending
Twitter officials tweets that they
wanted reviewed and you know let's call
this beta Spade probably taken down well
they were I mean the reply to it was
handled these uh so they were just dealt
with uh I think perhaps uh the sort of
Team Trump people who are getting very
excited about that exchange may have
over read into it a little bit over the
weekend because those links uh I think I
haven't checked them all myself because
you can't but they all uh linked to uh
pornographic images of Hunter Biden so
that was shutting down the pawn which
you know you could say not in the public
interest in Biden you know team Biden
had had a private interest in shutting
that down which Twitter acknowledged
um but then the bigger thing is of
course this New York Post story which
was very aggressively suppressed
and um I think it's also interesting
that issues of free speech are flagged
to uh Twitter officials so there's
actually a democratic rep out in
California he sends quite a lengthy
little essay about the importance of
free speech and the importance of
getting this balance right
um and also the difference between
someone who hacks and then a journalist
not involved in the hacking reporting
that story and why he thought Twitter
was on the wrong side of this divide I
mean even Biden supporters were getting
in touch just I mean I'm not suggesting
there were loads we only have one clear
example here but it isn't as if the
issues of the first amendment in free
speech weren't being flagged to Twitter
well precisely and indeed an internal
report was or external report was uh
commissioned and seems to have made it
clear that it didn't really think or
thought the First Amendment isn't
absolute there's a conclusion of it
which I think within the organization
clearly a lot of people were thinking
hang on we do have to think about First
Amendment uh and so that I think they
sort of they they discussed it a bit
they found this report that made them a
little bit better about the fact that
they were covering it all up do you
think some people were expecting a
bigger cover-up to be revealed I mean I
was reading through it and I was quite
shocked by what I was reading but then
on the other side I was like you know
these people seem nervous they seem
afraid of making the wrong decision you
really get a sense of doubling down on a
bad decision that's coming through you
know we just we can't U-turn uh you know
we can't look like we got the decision
wrong in the first place you don't get
these emails that are like you know in
order to make Biden win we must cover it
up there's none of that it's all just
kind of chaos it's well I agree there's
nothing actually that shocking and
almost in a way that's for me the
disturbing part is we all sort of know
that this happened but we've all sort of
accepted that it happened
um and the what about re part of it is
is where I think this story is
interesting uh even though I know people
dismiss water boundary but you know it's
worth going through what about if this
was Donald Trump Jr's laptop right I
mean that with no in a minute there
would be no such attempt to cover things
up no one would have cared about
pictures of Donald Trump Jr's penis I
mean well again they might have not
liked that but there wouldn't have been
this attempt they wouldn't have been the
sort of the very easy engagement between
the burden of Biden team we shouldn't
say administration because they were not
an Administration but there wouldn't
have been that just sort of assumption
that this is helping the wrong side
uh and so I think that's that's where
the real scandals Creeps in but you're
right there there hasn't been actually
anything that shocking I think the angle
that the New York Post is pursuing today
is more interesting and that's to do
with what were the FBI doing
um in the run-up to this and you know
were they using
uh sort of fear about what happened in
2016 which has pretty much mostly been
debunked anyway
um to silence a story that that people
within the American government did not
want to come out because it would have
helped Donald Trump win re-election you
know there's lots of scenery pieces this
weekend there's one by Tim Miller in the
the bullwalk uh saying you know this is
just Maga people wanting to look at
disgusting images of Joe Biden and
that's about all it amounts to I think
that's wrong I think there is a serious
story here and it has important uh
implications for free speech and things
like that I don't think it's just
right-wing not as getting upset well it
has big implications for the
relationship between government and
these massive social media companies as
well I mean here in the UK there's the
pursuit of the Online safety bill which
has a lot of problems for free speech
within that even the watered-down
version
um in the US you know there's always
talk about making moves on the social
media companies and it always seems to
further embed government decision making
into the top level decision making of
Twitter and meta and the rest of it and
I wonder if if the Twitter files will
actually be evidence that you know this
can be what happens when you have
government people interacting with the
social media people it always moves
towards censorship it always does and it
it's this difficult question of safety
you know it is hard in the UK the online
times bill that it is and the reason
that is good cover for political
censorship is because it is good cover
you know there does need to be concerns
about safety particularly in relation to
Children terrorism uh pornography and
foreign interference in elections
although I think that has actually been
proven to be a bit of a flub for just
trying to cover up stuff that you don't
want to come out
I think a lot of people on the mega
write over the years now have argued
that the hunter Biden laptop story could
have been akin to the Hillary Clinton
server story of 2016 when she hosted
that private server in her house to deal
with very confidential very official
emails from government
um and the claim was well gosh if
Twitter had allowed the story to come
out the results of the election would
have been different I am not convinced
I've never been convinced that these
stories are the same I'm not convinced
that the laptop story in 2020 would have
moved the dial significantly for Trump
the what we've seen from the Twitter
file so far and it is limited apparently
there is more to come as you say hasn't
convinced me to change my mind either
but what what do you make of the
response to the files so far
is it vindicating those who thought well
gosh you know we needed the story to win
or is this really not even about Trump
in 2020 anymore it's really a bigger
question about where social media
companies go from here when it comes to
uh Free Speech especially around
politics well I think the reaction to it
is interesting in that for uh you know
Mega people this was it you know finally
we you know we've got our Smoking Gun uh
and then for people who don't like Mega
people who were like well nothing's
there nothing's there this is not that
surprising this is what we thought
probably happened
um obviously the truth is somewhere in
between the two I think
um and I think in terms of sort of
whether it would have moved the dial you
can't really say
um and in fact I think there are there
might be quite good evidence to suggest
that the suppression of the story was so
weird that it's it didn't mobilize quite
helped yeah because it was so obvious
that big Tech was sort of stacking the
the deck against Trump
that it drove out the vote even more
yeah and indeed I think perhaps created
that climate of paranoia and conspiracy
theorizing that led to January 6th
because uh you know Donald Trump's team
never Justified the stolen election
narrative but at the same time they they
were right to say there are powerful
forces that are desperate to stop us
winning uh and that created this climate
of uh paranoia and anger and rage that
culminated in what you saw on January
6th the difficulty is that censorship is
always going to lead to more suspicion
it doesn't then go on to justify the
violent actions of other people using
that as an example
um but you know it is very uncomfortable
this idea that leading up to an election
in the states any social media company
would take you know a big news story
printed by the New York Post you know
the New York Post is on the right you
may not like the New York Post you may
not read the New York Post this is
mainstream media you know this is not
some blog by an Anonymous blogger who's
you know sharing some emails it's
credible and the idea of blocking a
credible mainstream Source from your
social media platform as you say it's
going to make people paranoid and and I
mean it boils down to I think then this
is why I think the poster right to
pursue the the FBI angle it boils down
to the old private companies can make
these decisions you know Twitter is a
private company could suppress uh
information if it wanted to it had the
right has the right to do that Elon Musk
as now the owner of it has the right to
release it uh but the interesting angle
all the explosive or dangerous angle I
think is uh to what extent with the FBI
intimidating uh big tech companies about
uh
warning them that they might be to blame
for some great political Calamity and we
have no evidence of that so far what are
you expecting from we do a bit of
another Zuckerberg has said that he was
told by the FBI to be on the lookout for
right right so Fred we've had this first
drop of the Twitter files and we may
well get more do you think that the
headlines are being reserved for a drop
later on the really big news or do you
think Elon Musk will have wanted to put
the information at
well I think what uh Toby and musk are
saying and their right to is that it is
odd that Legacy Publications or
corporate media are not are not that
interested in this story that could be
as some of them will say because
actually it hasn't revealed that much
but I think if this were a story of a
similar nature about a different
politician uh they might be a lot more
interested in it so I think that uh the
Twitter files will will bubble on and
there'll be a story that will be talked
about on Twitter In This Very meta to
confuse it even more with different
social media Platforms in this meta way
uh it'll become a way that Twitter
sustains interest in itself
um so I think it's a very very odd
Dynamic to have a social media company
sort of challenging its past self on
social media well the rest of the media
kind of looks on
well if there's another drop I'm sure
we'll be back here to discuss it Fred
thanks for joining me and thanks for
watching the view from 22.
[Music]